in a normal way by the way so maybe
like if i will find a challenge from wow
some 2900 guy
so scary
[Music]
he's also from argentina so it's
i don't know who is this guy but he's
definitely a grand master and he's
definitely a decent bliss player
okay let's
let's accept this challenge
[Music]
we want e5
normally not too brave against
qualified players
okay let's say bishop c5
bishop c5 already takes some
bravery to be honest
a4 okay can you play a5 here i guess you
can
and then pretty much whatever happens
you go bishop six as soon
or maybe you go bishop b6 first and then
you go bishop
b6 a certain general when the pawn
structure the
the queen side is set this way
this bishop takes a6 takes f takes
positions are
quite safe for um for black but
i could be wrong it has never been my
sort of pet opening
yeah it actually starts to look a bit
strange from wine but okay
whatever
he probably knows what he's doing
yeah knight c4 so should we yeah we
probably go to
a7 and bishop is three so we'll probably
trade i would say knight takes
i always play some
some random logical moves like windy
seven queen f7 then we'll probably start
considering knight h5 unless he will
play g3
it also makes sense to bring this rook
to it or did but some queen b3
will have to
face by
playing rook b normally
okay so let's show some
some ambitions let's go knight h5
didn't want to play queen f7 because now
we pretend that we we can also play uh
rook takes f3
i don't know if it's true or not but
like as white you are probably a bit
worried about it
yeah so now we go knight f4
i don't think it
changes much in terms of the
like objective evaluation but it's
definitely a bit uncomfortable for white
like optically it feels like
black starts coming all over the world
the world
wanted to save the board
anyway okay rock f6 bring another rook
to a fade go rook g6
yeah he plays h4 himself which makes
sense
okay let's bring the rook anyway
like to to complete this setup you
normally need to play g3 but it it
always runs into knight h3 check
so it's not that easy for uh for white
to get what he wants like the ideal
setup would be knight g4 g3 king g2 then
it's very safe
and you never run into
into any kind of trouble with the king
side or at least i think so but
yeah he plays knight g4 rook g6
now h5 is probably straight so he wants
to play g3 i believe
and then we'll have to figure out what's
wrong with it but there should be
something wrong
first of all there is no even threat
so we can just play something like queen
f7 or uh
or h5 maybe yeah maybe h5 is what's
wrong so g3 h5 g takes e takes f4 simply
black is crushing okay so he played uh
he played rogue d2 instead looks very
bad for white
um
some knight g4 is also in there
and also just play queen e7 attacking h4
g3 h5
knight h2 queen takes h4
king h1 queen h3
looks convincing to me okay let's do
this
yeah so now we are liking um attacking
the h4 pawn so i think g3 is uh
i mean it's not a must but if you don't
play it you're sort of busted so you
have to do this
now knight h2 is also kind of forced
yeah so we take
king h1 and then we will think like we
can also play
something slow like win
not h3
he plays d4 which allows rook takes g3
and it should be crushing i would say
i'm a bit too lazy to calculate but it
looks way too good not to play it
okay whatever
so if he goes to f1 then we have like a
billion of checks yeah he just resigns
okay fair enough
and he offers uh very much okay he's
2900
deserves some respect here so let's play
the guy
a bit more e6 okay let's say bishop g5
and takes
and e4
d5 okay this is my favorite banter blitz
opening i think the engine says
black is uh like almost better here or
like slightly better
but to me it feels like very
natural play for white
the stakes go queenie too like castle
long try to checkmate
a very natural thing
he castles yeah so do we start some
some kind of action immediately
we can also play it in a quiet way
just to you know
just to show the people we can also
play positional chance
but i already start feeling like
this whole plan will fail
and i'll regret not playing
not playing aggressively
c3 why would i place a string it's
probably useful move
maybe that's why okay
knight b3
looked a bit more ambitious maybe based
on some
you know some d4 isn't there
also d4
e5 white is probably crashing okay
plays bishop d7 let's play knight b3
anyway
now i have some bishop b1 followed by q
industry
in mind
bishop b1 looks like a good eye or
bishop c2
looks like a nice idea in general so we
are setting the battery
we we're also attacking d5
and he sort of doesn't know what we're
up to
he just
takes fair enough so takes and now f5
okay
so what he played is a very very
ambitious approach
and it cannot be
sort of just okay it's either he's on
time and black is just better
or
he's not in time and then it's
problematic for black
or it's equal okay let's go rookie one
he will probably play bishop c8 unless
it's blunder but i don't say why would
it be
would it be a blunder
so bishop c8 we take on d8 and go a4
maybe
like it's very much about e65 happening
or not basically if black gets
e5
without blundering something then he
will be just better
yeah that's why he plays king kitchen so
he wants to
he wants to play e5
but we need to come up with some tricks
like a4 maybe
so the point is e5 a5
and it looks good also in some of the
lines we'll probably go
like i don't know
knight g5 or something some bishop a2
will be
will be useful idea okay he just plays
a5
can i play knight c5 knight c5 runs into
like knight e7 or knight b8
we have some knight e5 there
you know it's hard to tell it's quite a
mess actually
yeah also if it's black to move and he
plays e5 and then we go knight h4 he has
he has king h7 right no he doesn't
maybe he has uh
yeah it's not that simple
all right let's try knight c5 like
normally when i don't know what to do i
play some
random aggressive move
yeah 97 okay so if we go 95 the plan is
bishop takes c5
knight takes d7 bishop takes f2 that's
why we have to play b4 assad
but what's wrong with b4 i do not yet
see
i am in a
emperor i probably missed something but
i don't see it yet
like we don't care about this bishop
takes c4 or something we just need to
play knight t5 and then we're good
basically
like once we play 95 and stabilize it
even if we
it will sort of
take us sacrificing the pawn it will be
fine
he plays knight g6
i'm preventing this
knight e5
i suggest we go bishop a2
protecting the queen so now knight takes
d7 is the threat so he has to take and
he does
now we'll probably go b takes
and then again we have this fight like
we probably want to play like h4 h5
knight e5 or maybe rook d6
so black has to be very fast
like e5 for d6 e4 maybe or something but
it doesn't work zone
yeah maybe we are kind of outplaying him
maybe bishop c6 works
but in terms of concrete moves i to be
honest i do not see
like a really good way for black
but my intuition is saying black is like
almost fine maybe
but maybe not actually
maybe we just played a very nice game
and sort of all played him yeah he plays
bishop c but it looks a bit too slow
like we can play h4
he wants to take on d1 and go 95 takes
takes rook d6
or q d4 even
we can also take on d8 first and then go
h4
yeah let's probably do this here
so we give up the
d file which is obviously
not something to be proud of but on the
other hand we
sort of claim it's way more important to
get
to get uh 95
and he plays queen g5 so after h5 what's
the plan
so he simply wants to take on c5 yeah
which i missed completely
okay is there some tactics there
like rook takes c6
would be brilliant actually
but it probably doesn't work
yeah
so what should i do maybe i just go c6
first
like if i
lose the spawn anyway i want to make
sure
i lose it on the right square sort of
now maybe queen e2 and then we get our
like
oh this move i actually missed
okay
yeah i obviously blundered a few things
but it's probably still a game of chess
sort of
yeah now he'll probably take on h4
and it's some mess again
no he doesn't
okay i don't know g3
uh okay she takes maybe
so who is making kung he has this queen
h5 we have rook d8
okay he goes there
let me show p6 okay let's play something
yeah queen g3 so queen takes d1 is
probably a draw
okay shank
go back so can we play it we can also
play knight f7 and repeat it this
way yeah
so queen h would be a bit too much here
that's how i feel at least
yuck seems to be wrong
okay
okay shark bean
he wants one more no i guess we'll
switch to playing uh
you